just how long will it be until this
is within reach for us all the beach in
tel aviv is beginning to come back to
life as israel leads the global vaccine
race
some say this is far too quick a foolish
rush for normality
the country is certainly a test case for
the world through the course of this
pandemic israel seems to have been just
ahead of everyone else the first
to lock down hard in march last year the
first to emerge from a lockdown
way too quickly it turned out there are
plenty of lessons to learn from here
both positive and negative
the israeli vaccine program has been an
unquestionable success they are now
vaccinating everyone over the age of 16
40 of the country has been jabbed but
look at this
empty chairs that experts here say
countries globally should be prepared
for
because younger generations it seems are
less interested in the vaccine
vaccination rate has gotten considerably
slower
and that's the concern here right now
how to convince young healthy people
to get vaccinated the sooner the better
the good news is that the real world
data here shows that the vaccines
are working there are fewer older people
in hospital but worryingly
more younger ones on the other side of
the city the sheba medical center is the
country's largest hospital
inside again we found the vaccine
centers empty
here they've been forced to take the
vaccines out to the community
and then this is the challenge this is
the iceberg
dr a.l leshen will be briefing the
scottish government this week
there is global interest in israel's
experience
you really need to convince them you
need to prepare the communication
move in to work in in social media move
and work with community leaders
opinion leaders even celebrities just
making sure that people understand it's
safe
and it's it's really important for
everyone to get vaccinated so we can get
back to normal life
the road back to the beach passes
through one of the country's
ultra-orthodox communities
here there is real reluctance to be
vaccinated and the infection rate is
huge
but it is the young in all communities
who the government needs to encourage
most prefer not to that's what i think
why is that
uh they're afraid i think have you had a
vaccine yet
yes i had the first one you have but you
haven't no why not
yes he's afraid
but why are you afraid
eventually he'll do it because he thinks
it will be mandatory
the latest proposal is to ban anyone who
hasn't been vaccinated from bars
shops and restaurants draconian
certainly
but necessary they think so mark stone
sky news in israel